what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and once again I'm here to talk
about the latest developments in Demon
Slayer specifically this time we're
going to get more in depth with one of
my favorite characters you're Ichi the
strongest demons they're in history so
look forward to that if you like seeing
Demon Slayer videos on this channel and
want to keep them coming make sure to
smash that like button to let me know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
ring that notification bell because
otherwise you won't get notified when
you would even say our videos and
updates come out for even more Demon
Slayer content and crucial updates about
the upcoming movie and seasons make sure
to follow us on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar keep in mind in this video
there will be manga spoilers we are
going to be talking about the latest
developments after all now without
further ado let's jump into it
in the last chapter Coco Chabot revealed
and evolve in hideous demon form this
seemed to be the final stage of demon
evolution that Icaza almost attained it
appears that if demons make it to this
point they can regrow their heads and
can't be killed except through sunlight
so having lost Muccino in kenya it
seemed like yo me and simon me no longer
stood a chance
however just when it seemed like he was
unstoppable coco she booked on a glimpse
of his own reflection inside of a sword
he seemed to realize in that moment that
he had lost his way just like a casa in
a causes case he stopped trying to get
stronger because he regained his
memories and realized that he no longer
had a reason to get stronger since the
people he wanted to protect with that
strength were long dead for Coco Cibo he
realized that he always wanted to be the
strongest samurai but he was no longer a
samurai at all he had become a monster
who had nothing in common with a samurai
he betrayed every samurai code in order
to attain more power and escaped death
when he realized that this wasn't what
he really wanted his body began to
dissolve where Mui Chiu stabbed him with
his red blade his last thought was that
he wanted to be like his younger twin
brother yo Deecee that takes us to the
current chapter which is also amazing we
get the backstory of kakushi bow and
your ichi which happens to be a really
interesting one like I always say I am
psyched when we get more information
about your Ichi and this is probably the
chapter that gives us the most
information about him the chapter is
called little brother and it starts off
with Coco she bows saying how
people who don't feel jealous are lucky
they're lucky because they never met
someone like you Ichi someone who lives
the favor of the gods lavished upon them
then we get a really beautiful line we
are told that people like your Ichi burn
like the Sun so fiercely they consume
everything around them as they say the
brightest light casts the darkest shadow
and Koko she bowls life was spent right
in the middle of that shadow in other
words because your Ricci's talent always
shines so bright kuku she was left in
the darkness starved for attention this
light versus darkness metaphor is
further emphasized by the fact that you
each he used the breath of the Sun style
compared to Koko she bows breath of the
moon style it is clear that Koko she bow
has a huge inferiority complex because
of his talented brother so let's see how
it developed as we know the two were
born twins yo Deecee immediately had the
mark on his forehead and it was
considered ominous their father actually
wanted to kill you Ichi he actually only
survived because his mother upon hearing
that her husband wanted to kill you Ichi
erupted an uncontrollable anger like a
sudden inferno it was thanks to her
diary she was spared rather than killing
him they decided that he would
eventually be sent to the temple at the
age of 10 where he would enter the
priesthood the two twins were raised in
a completely different manner kuku shiva
was raised as a chosen one who would go
on to become the head of the family as a
result he had a better room better
clothes better food and a better
education the father was clearly picking
favorites early on and Coco Chiba was
the clear favorite he was told from a
young age that he was special and better
than his little brother yo Deecee was
always glued to his mom's left side kuku
Shiba pitied him you would eat cheap
late in a small room and Coco Chiba
would secretly visit him behind his
father's back their father didn't want
kuku she bows seeing his little brother
so cuckoo Shiba couldn't give you an eg
anything he owned even if he wanted to
because their father would notice in
this way he was prevented from sharing
the wealth that came with being the
favorite however because of this he made
a flute and gave it to his little
brother this is a really beautiful
moment that we should stop and
appreciate kuku she will clearly wasn't
a bad person
despite his father clearly establishing
a narrative where he was superior to his
lower brother Coco she will didn't abuse
that power
there he cared about his little brother
and even gave him gifts when he wasn't
supposed to as Sirius Black says in
Harry Potter and I really like this
quote if you want to know what a man's
like take a good look at how he treats
his inferiors not as equals and quote &
Co Co Chabot treated his brother kindly
as far as we can tell which goes to show
that he was naturally a good person
despite the terrible influence of his
father little UD chido didn't smile for
the longest time even when he received
the flute
he never even spoke until the age of
seven so people thought he was deaf
until then but then one day when he was
watching his brother practices
horsemanship skills he spoke fluently
out of nowhere the first thing he ever
said was about his big brother he asked
him if his dream was to become the
strongest samurai in the land
kikuchiyo was so surprised that his
brother could talk let alone talk
fluently that his breath halted and he
dropped his sword this was the beginning
of the role reversal that would take
place between the brothers yo Deecee
started saying that he also wanted to
become a samurai and then he smiled for
the first time the little unhappy quiet
brother that Kakashi Bo had always
pitied was suddenly talking and smiling
it unnerved kakushi Bo perhaps because
he says that their relationship was
beginning to change
cuckoo Shiba thought at first that it
was impossible for your ichi someone who
cling to his mother's side whenever he
saw her to become a samurai because
samurai had to be willing to risk their
lives in battle
no mama's boy could do that so cuckoo
Shiba thought it would never happen how
wrong he was one day while Kakashi bo
was being trained in swordsmanship
yuuichi showed up to watch kakushi Bo's
trainer decided to humor your each year
he gave him a bamboo sword he verbally
told him how to use it and then the
trainer took a ready stance he had no
idea what was about to happen this kid
who had never held a sword in his life
absolutely wrecked him koko Cibo trained
and trained and he could never land a
hit on his trainer his first time you
and ichi in the blink of an eye hit him
four times and knocked him down flat as
a seven year old who'd never even held a
sword yuuichi gave the sword expert for
fist sized welts all over his body I'm a
younger brother myself so I can't fully
understand how an older brother feels
but I think we would all be at least
a little upset if we spent years
practicing something and our younger
sibling tried it for the first time and
completely surpassed us especially if we
always thought that we were superior to
that sibling in every way you can't help
but feel for Koko Cibo if he was a jerk
to his little brother from the beginning
then it would be a different story we
would love to see the younger dog
completely crushed the spoiled bully but
since Koko Shiva was always nice to his
little brother we can sympathize with
him here after he completely crushed the
swordsmanship expert at the age of seven
Iori she actually said he no longer
wanted to be a samurai he couldn't stand
how hitting people feels kakushi bodo
wanted to know the secret to your ichi
strength it turns out that even at seven
years old you reach he had access to the
see-through world the one that yo made
the strongest pillar just gained access
to during the most recent fight against
Kakashi Bo your each she told kakushi Bo
to take a good look at his skeletal
alignment muscle contraction blood flow
that sort of thing of course this meant
nothing to Kakashi bow at the time
because he didn't yet have access to the
see-through world eventually Coco's evil
figured out that for your ichi living
bodies were transparent yuri cheese mark
which was at first thought to be a bad
omen was actually what gave him
extraordinary insight and equally
extraordinary physical prowess and this
is where we get a really important line
where it all sinks in for Coco see Bo he
says and I quote the person whom I had
until that moment look down on had far
outstripped me and quote at this point
kuku she was fully realized just how out
of his League his little brother who he
thought was an untalented mess just a
little while ago truly is ironically
though your teach he doesn't seem like
he wants these extraordinary talents he
says he'd rather play a Japanese dice
game or fly kites with his big brother
then talk about swords it seems like he
wants to do stuff he isn't better than
his brother at he wants to bond and have
fun with his brother rather than make
his brother feel bad about his own
swordsmanship skills however Coco Shiba
was always obsessed with swordsmanship
he had accepted that the path to mastery
would involve pain and hardship but he
knew that if he put every ounce of
effort into his training he could grow
strong yet next to you Ichi the
miraculous
prodigy Coco Siebel was moving at a
turtle's pace ironically cuckoo Shiva
wanted desperately to be the best
swordsman but he didn't have great
talent and you're Ichi who did have the
talent seem painfully board by
discussions about sword fighting udg
despite being a once-in-a-lifetime
genius at swordsmanship didn't take joy
in his talent the way of the sword was
nothing more than a children's game for
him
Kaku Shiva was scared he knew that his
father was told about your reach his
great talent he feared that they would
switch places with his father's eyes
your each he would become the heir and
samurai while Coco Chabot would be sent
to the temple
then one night duty she visited him he
told Coco Co that their mother had died
URI she says that he is Coco she bows
retainer a case someone of inferior rank
taken on to serve at the leaders
pleasure even though he is stronger than
Coco she bow at this point you and Ichi
wants to serve under his brother he
tells KOCO Shiva that he's leaving for
the temple immediately and just wanted
to say goodbye he also shows Coco Chabot
the flute he gave him in the past
although he didn't smile when he
received it your Ichi is smiling now for
your Ichi his older brother is the most
important person in his life he gets
strength by thinking about him and how
kind he was to him he says he will
strive day after day no matter how far
from home he drifts he will not lose
heart because he will think of his elder
brother who gave him this flute even
though it was a pretty crappy flute that
could produce nothing but off-key notes
udg treated it like it was his most
precious treasure because his brother
gave it to him your Ichi then bowed to
his brother deeply and with almost no
belongings left the house through his
mother's diary cuckoo she will learn say
your each she realized he would usurp
cuckoo Shiva's place as air he left
before that decision can be made then we
figure out that your each he knew
everything about his mother's illness
while cocoa Shiva was protected from it
yo Deecee was constantly helping her it
wasn't that your Ichi was a crybaby who
needed to cling to his mother your Ichi
as a child was actually supporting his
mother so she could walk with less pain
the left side of her body grew more and
more impaired and you each she was the
one taking care of her while Coco Shiba
didn't even have to worry about it
so what she will thought that your Ichi
was a spoiled
boy he was actually the one responsible
for taking care of their sick parent at
such a young age
this fact infuriates Kakashi Bo he is so
upset it even appears like he starts
bleeding from his nose he crumples the
pages of the diary he can feel his body
being consumed by the flames of jealousy
from inside out from the very bottom of
his soul he blazed with hatred for their
genius known as your Ichi then we are
told that the brothers are separated by
a wall called Talent at the end of the
chapter so what's with Coco she bows
reaction
how dare he hate the guy who loves him
sacrificed everything for him and even
took care of his mother when she was
sick well I believe in large part this
has to do with the way Coco Shiba was
raised he was constantly treated like
the superior one people thought his
brother was completely untalented and
that he couldn't even talk he got used
to this arrangement he got used to being
the better one the superior one he got
used to pitying his poor less fortunate
brother
then one day it all got turned around
his brother began talking he began
kicking butt with a sword and he was
revealed to be a more selfless caring
person than Coco Tchibo he selflessly
took care of his mother until she died
then as soon as she died and no longer
needed him he left so as not to get in
Coco she bows way he also took great joy
in a crappy flute while Coco Chabot had
so many more luxuries and was still
unhappy to make things worse Coco Shiva
was saved by his little brother who he
looked down on until just recently that
was a huge wound to Kakashi Bo's pride
while coach people feared being sent to
the temple your Ichi was braver he
willingly abandoned a life of comfort
and left on his own kuku Shiba thought
his whole brother wasn't brave enough to
be a samurai before but in truth he was
always braver than him all of these
things make okishima feel worthless like
a greatly inferior version of your Ichi
and he would carry this feeling around
his whole life this chapter also
explains why you're a teach he cried
when he fought against Coco Tchibo it's
because you had each he cared about his
brother more than anyone else in the
world and he felt sorry that he'd lost
his way and become a demon he truly
wished the best for his brother this
after also suggests that my one
assumption may be right namely the
assumption that your each she couldn't
bring himself to kill his brother
because he cared about him too much like
we saw your each she was quick enough to
slice coca she bows neck he definitely
could have finished him off with this /
but he didn't and then he passed away
right after that to me it seems even
more likely after this chapter that he
just couldn't bring himself to kill the
most important person in his life let me
know what you think do you kind of get
how Coco Cibo feels do you understand
how he became a monster or do you think
that he should just have been happy and
appreciative for his talented younger
brother who was willing to sacrifice
everything for him although it's easy to
judge I do think that the mangaka does a
good job of illustrating where Coco
Chabot is coming from and that is it for
this chapter there was less fighting in
this one but I'm glad that we got this
much-needed backstory and additional
information about the epic you're a
chief if you enjoyed the video make sure
to smash that like button to let me know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
ring that notification bell so you
actually get notified when you chapter
reviews drop a big thank you goes to our
patrons over on patreon who help make
videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our procure to
your patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings
August angel Cruz Steelers boy Pablo
atropos Wraith Finney dolla beat a
Karachi and Anatoly Cassatt's ki and DJ
Nathaniel and are the one to your
patrons the ones who stay atop all plans
Steven and Radha a Lola not temp Mattie
Mac 239 makoto-kun and Seth Cooper if
you enjoy our work you can support more
of it by going over to patreon calm
animals roar and becoming a patron today
for as little as $1 if you do so you'll
get your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to a
private patron only discord so check out
patreon calm and my uproar link in the
description if you're interested you can
also now join the YouTube channel and
support more content that way if you
prefer and until next time see you bass
cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]